[Music]
Kate Forbes recently the front runner
for the SNP leadership race has
plummeted in the polls after a tough
week facing questions about her
religious views a devout member of the
Free Church of Scotland Forbes
personally believes that having children
out of wedlock is wrong as is gay
marriage but shouldn't matter with
someone in politics thinks in their
private life David Robertson who is also
part of the Free Church writes for the
spectator's website this week and he
joins me now
David thanks for joining spectator TV
tell us about the Free Church of
Scotland which has been in the news this
week as of the past few weeks a lot of
people didn't really know about it yeah
there are people who would know what
kind of caricature we were nicknamed the
we threes and the idea is that you know
we're a bunch of do are miserable
Scottish Calvinists who live on the
island speak Gaelic and never do
anything on a Sunday the caricature is
the only time the Free Church would get
in the news is if we announced that our
policy on the nuclear bomb was we didn't
want them to drop it on a Sunday so
there's a caricature thing of that but
in the 21st century the Free Church
somewhat surprisingly has grown and uh I
would say it's a conservative
theologically but not conservative
politically you can't confuse those two
things
um it a group of about a hundred
churches about 13 000 attenders
growing in the cities declining in some
other areas
but uh
yeah it's it's a bible-believing
conservative theologically Presbyterian
church and we break that down we now
know that Cape Forbes the SMP candidate
for first minister is a part of it and
you've repeated this phrase
theologically conservative what exactly
does that mean
it means that we accept the Bible for
what it is now people say do you mean
literally well it it literally depends
what they mean by literally so when
Jesus says I'm a door he doesn't mean
he's wooden and got a handle but what we
mean is that we we believe every word of
the Bible is true that we read it in
context in the different genres but we
think it applies to today so we're very
uh very much a bible-based church
um some people want to use the
pejorative fundamentalist I don't agree
I I think all of us have fundamental
beliefs anyway we think that we need to
apply the Bible to Modern Life
what we don't think we have the Liberty
to do is to pick and choose which bits
of the Bible we like um I think it was
Saint Augustine who said if you believe
in the Bible what you like and leave out
what you don't like it's not the Bible
you believe but yourself
so
um I I think that there are people who
like to mock us as being somewhat
ignorant
um
I think one of the problems in the UK is
we are so influenced by American Media
that when people hear the word bible
believing or something they tend to
think of Southern redneck Evangelical
which I think is a bit unfair on the
southern uh people as well but it's a
caricature and so they
they tend to think of that except in
Scottish terms you've written a piece
in a piece website and in that piece you
mentioned that whoms are Yusuf
Yusuf and been taken to task about his
faith but he was asked on BBC Radio 4
whether he thinks gay marriage and gay
sex are wrong so why do you think that
this issue is specific to Christians
oh I don't think it is I think it's Ian
warter who's an atheist the Scottish um
journalist brilliant writer who said
basically humza Yusuf and Cape Forbes
both belong to religions that condemn
homosexuality and gay marriage or
homosexual practice at least in
Christianity and gay marriage
and uh the the difference said my water
is that one of them's a hypocrite and
one of them is a Believer
um I I think that what was done with
Kate Forbes was an absolute Hatchet job
everybody knew what she believed and
it's utterly irrelevant I mean here we
are today Hamza Yusuf has just had a
report about the National Health Service
in Scotland which is devastating about
his management people are dying because
of that and that's not what people are
interested in they're interested in a
hypothetical of Kate Forbes who was 20
at the time when the same-sex marriage
stuff went through the Scottish
Parliament how she would have voted
there is no possibility of the Scottish
Parliament voting on same-sex marriage
in the next two parliaments at least
so I mean this is very much a handy job
and I think this is really unfair people
are having a go at Cape Forbes for
something holding a position that to be
honest a third of people in the UK still
hold and that was the normal position in
society up until about five minutes ago
Yusuf has been challenged on specifics
in the Quran and he has suggested that
his Progressive beliefs he feels can gel
with his religious beliefs Kate Forbes
has been asked as you say about how she
would have voted on gay marriage when
she was a very young woman but is the
bigger question here not how she would
have voted on gay marriage but what's
going to happen when other social issues
come up in Hollywood because whilst you
say in your peace that Kate Forbes has
said that her beliefs would not change
how she votes she is hinted quite
strongly that had she had that vote back
in the day it would have affected her
vote and perhaps the question for
Scottish voters is what else might come
up I mean the trans issue is still very
much on the table in Scotland with which
she would use her personal religious
leanings to legislate that to me is the
ultimate question for every candidate
well the ultimate question actually it's
not just personal religious beliefs
everyone has philosophical religious
beliefs everyone
so the the question is to what extent do
your personal beliefs affect things now
you mentioned the grr that's that's a
great one um two-thirds of Scottish
people actually agree with cape Forbes
on this
isn't it ironic that we live I mean I
find this almost laughable that we live
in a world in which when a candidate is
asked what is a transgender woman say
the transgender woman is a biological
man
who wants to live as a woman
and she has been reported to the NEC of
the SMP for hate speech
and what's interesting about that is
humza Yusuf is the man who passed the
hate speech laws in Scotland
which would mean that in theory she
could go to jail for actually saying
something that is biologically
scientifically and rationally true so I
actually don't agree that when someone
says my beliefs won't affect how I vote
of course they will Kate Forbes
passionate passionately believes because
of her time in India where her parents
were serving in a charity for the poor
that she needs to do the best she can to
help the poor she passionately believes
that she passionately believes in
justice so I I think it's very foolish
to say you wouldn't allow your beliefs
to affect they certainly do I'm I have
to say I'm not sure at all what holmesa
believes to pick up on that point then
isn't the question for Scottish voters
because she is being very honest and
very clear about what she believes what
the trade-offs are for them because as
you say the majority of Scottish voters
happen to agree with Kate Forbes on the
trans issue plenty of them will agree
with her on the independence issue and
lots of other issues I'm sure there are
a lot of people out there who will be
nervous about the concept of hate speech
and and what can and cannot be said that
could potentially land you in prison and
certainly the way it's being interpreted
today but lots of people will disagree
with her about the rights for gay people
to get married or her comments about
having children outside of marriage and
they're weighing up which side they're
more comfortable with I mean there are
trade-offs here and that's something
that if you know in your own words Kate
Forbes is going to use her own beliefs
as she if she were to become first
Minister isn't don't the Scottish people
have the right to then weigh that up and
say well I agree with this I disagree
with this and you know they might decide
that the disagreements outweigh the
agreements
I I agree completely and I think the
Scottish people should decide that who
should not decide that is the twitterity
and I'm sorry to say this but
journalists so right now what I'm
hearing from people so I know that uh a
couple of days ago thousands of messages
of support were pouring in for Kate
Forbes
um I know that Nicholas sturgeon has got
involved today because she's really
shocked that that Kate Forbes has not
banked not banged down I would suggest
to you that um this is almost like a
Jacob Reed smog moment do you remember
that time when Jacob Reese morgue was
asked on I think it was on ITV good
morning what do you think about abortion
and he said well I'm against it and you
could almost see the journalist
salivating I've got him he's dead you
know and at the end of that I remember
that um
the guardian I think the next day ran a
headline which ineffectively said Jacob
Reese smorg finished
well in the in the Westminster bubble
and in the Hollywood bubble that's true
but in the world of real people he
wasn't and I know Penn plenty people his
popularity soared in the following weeks
because there were plenty of people who
said I don't agree with him but oh my
goodness thank God for an honest
politician and I think Kate Forbes the
irony here is we have
people asking about a policy and
politicians should be judged on their
policy if you're going to judge people
on their character again with all due
respect Boris Johnson would never get in
you know and I think most politicians
we've had a bizarre situation in
Scotland here where experts have been
saying if only she lied
done what Tim fahren did which Tim
fahren now bitterly regrets which was a
very foolish thing I think the people
who are at fault here are the people who
are constantly asking her about gay sex
and same-sex marriage none of which is
relevant to the policies that the
Scottish government will be dealing with
over the next few years
the business Community love her if you
ask the business Community who they want
the Tories by the way I'll tell you this
I know this from speaking to many Tories
Tori leaders
they kind of like cape Forbes but
they're desperate that she doesn't get
elected because if she gets elected the
Tories are finished in Scotland
because she will win a lot of Tory votes
I guess my last question to you is that
difference between Jake Chris Smog and
Kate Forbes is that Jacob rees-mogg has
never put himself forward for the top
job and by doing that naturally it comes
with all kinds of new scrutiny and as
you say it's for the people of Scotland
to decide for the s p to decide who they
want to lead the country but if they are
curious about the answers to her
questions about for example what she
thinks of having a child outside of
marriage is it not right that she's
asked the question so they at least get
their answer and can make an informed
decision
no because that's not the basis on which
normal people make their decisions
very quickly very quickly it might be
when it comes to how would she legislate
for welfare how would she treat single
parent families well is the s p going to
do for these people are these not
legitimate questions to know what she
thinks from first principles
absolutely but that's not what they're
doing you see when that question is
being asked it's been asked us I got
your question
Kate Forbes more than anyone else in the
SMP leadership is talking about poverty
and everything else that's for concern
when she's asked what is best for a
child she says well I think it's best
for a child to grow up with a mother and
father virtually every study agrees with
that now the the the degradation of the
family is what is devastated Scotland I
used to work in housing Estates in
Dundee and you know I do kids camps in
19 out of the 20 kids you couldn't say
to them go home to your mum and dad they
were growing up fatherless or they were
growing up now that that is to say that
something is the best is not to
denigrate single mothers and I think
it's slanderous to imply that because
Kate Forbes thinks his best for a child
to grow up with two parents that she's
attacking single parents I don't think
that's true at all I think she will do
more welfare for the I mean the SNP have
been a disaster for the poor in Scotland
and I know because my city was Dundee
but she is in the SNP I mean the the
part of you're criticizing is also and
the party that K Forbes is representing
yes absolutely and and believe you me
although Kate Forbes is a member of my
church if she was if she I think the
last chance for the SNP by the way is
Kate Forbes the s p want to commit
suicide they will and they'll do it
because of religion but not because of
Christianity because of the green
Progressive religion which has taken
over people's minds here we had a first
minister of Scotland who when asked if a
rapist was a a man or a woman could not
answer
now I'm sorry that made us the laughing
stock of the world I'm here in Australia
and and people were just thinking is
this a Monty Python skit because it was
so ridiculous so I think Cape Forbes
people may not like her social views a
lot of people do but I think it's deeply
unfair that she's been condemned for her
social views when other people's social
views are not being discussed and I
think it's even worse that the real
policies are not being discussed so she
should be challenged on how you're going
to pay for Independence and so should
all the other the candidates I'm a
supporter of independence by the way so
I'll confess to that but I still think
that they've never answered that they
need to be challenged on the NHS they
need to be challenged on education
Scotland has the worst drugs deaths in
Europe if not the world and that needs
to be challenged on that by the way you
said something very very interesting I
need to admit to deal with this you said
going to the top job I'm a Democrat
um and to be honest I'm pretty well a
republican as well and I'm far more
left-wing than most of these so-called
progressives who are not Progressive at
all they're a bunch of rich kids who've
been indoctrinated with some stuff from
Harvard and Yale and Oxford and
Cambridge and think it's wonderful and
think they can keep their millions and
then say that they're billionaire
socialists or something I'm not like
that I think that we should have a
proper democracy I don't care if Kate
Forbes is an MP a leader a finance
minister or or you know the first
minister to me in Scotland and I think
in the UK we we don't have a
presidential system I I don't want
somebody who you go oh that's our great
leader
um I think Nicholas sturgeon governed
like that and I think it's been a
disaster she has left my country
absolutely devastated I think Cape
Forbes has a slight possibility of being
able to rebuild it precisely because of
our Christian values hey Forbes
interviewed recently and I saw her five
questions on sex
you know what nerve I mean people go oh
you Christians are all obsessed by sex
we're not obsessed by it
it's the media that are obsessed by sex
nothing about industry nothing about
farming nothing about education nothing
about the NHS and I know what the people
of Scotland care more about and it's
certainly not Progressive issues that
seem to this bubble that people seem to
live in that they're not the issues that
we're concerned about David thanks for
joining me
[Music]